women 25 years old Sparks Fierce debate
after Brandon College as scam this is a
Daily Mail
story uh we wrote a book on this a
couple years ago Tom uh let me go to
what is it what page page here we go
okay women 25 years old Sparks spars
debate after branding College as a scam
October 23rd stored from Daily Mail
college graduate Allison Johnson 25
years old ignited a fierce debate on TiK
ToK by denouncing college as scam
revealing her $80,000 debt and her
struggle to secure a well-paying job in
her field in her video which ared over
539,000 views she Express her
frustration stating I have I have my
literal business marketing degree which
put me $80,000 in debt and I make more
serving Sushi roles Allison emphasized
her difficulty in updating marketing
jobs where entry-level positions offered
meager salaries compared to her current
waitressing job she questioned the value
of her education raising doubts about
what her investment in college was
worthwhile weather I'm he I'm headed to
my serving job and I'm effting it
meanwhile I make more money serving than
I would at an entry-level marketing job
she lament to Tom thoughts on this so
there's there's three things going on
here the first thing is she doesn't
really like her current job but she's
keeping it to survive because she can
make money on it the second thing is
she's actually a college graduate she
actually got through there and the third
thing is
$80,000 for in debt she's basically
bought a giant Ford F-150 crew cab
pickup all tricked out that's basically
folks as if she had walked out of
college and bought that kind of debt so
what's going on here is she has a point
the point she has is I can't find a job
that I can afford to go to and because
of my student debt because of what got
on top of that and you know I can make
more waiting tables well you know what
you can do that on day one right it's
called you where are you gonna be in 10
years with that marketing degree you're
not going to be in the same spot you're
going to put it to work and by the way
you have a marketing degree you're doing
pretty good on social media pleading
your case here so you're you're
marketing yourself pretty well but this
is this is this is a truth the tuitions
are up at crazy levels you go there to
be indoctrinated you end up 880,000 in
debt and now you're at a job you really
don't like because you just have to make
ends me but let me tell you those lines
are going to cross and that's what she's
not pointing out and that's not what all
the the the liberal sympathizers are are
not seeing is that if she puts her
shoulder to the load in that career
she's going to be making far more than
waiting tables so you don't like what
you can make on day one walking out with
your marketing degree With No E no
experience but you're going to make
experience and that the lines are going
to cross here the real issue is you
knowingly accepted the fact where you
selected where to go to college that
you're going to be $80,000 in debt and
tuition is not tuition is not cheap and
so she makes a point here about the I
don't think it's about the student loan
crisis the point is is the tuition
crisis tuition inflation over the last
30 years which is ridiculous compared to
just normal CPI Consumer Price Index and
normal and so I think she has a point
about that but she's not paying
attention that if you just put some work
in it you can get there Kavon can I ask
you a question sure to can I do a quick
case study with Kon case study here Kon
you wanted to be uh comedian you
discovered you had some talent for it
what were you paid when they would give
you what do they call fives you can do a
five minute like in between two big
comedians what were you paid for that
french fries if I was lucky seriously oh
have a have a burger and french fries
not Burger he hey who said you have a
burger no we got we had a drink we had
they'd give us a drink or like a bottle
of water or Coca-Cola right you get a
little ticket I want my Coca-Cola yeah
that's it you're we we weren't paid and
when you're fin or how long did you do
that probably for about a year and a
half two years okay and when you finally
got paid for maybe a 5 minute at a
better part of the night you're going to
go right between our two guys at 9 and
10:00 I'm giving you a prime 5:00 Prime
5 minutes how much was that 20 bucks and
I would let them pile up so I go get six
checks I'm like to feel better yeah yeah
exactly now then two years later what
were you doing okay so two years after
that probably $100 to $300 a show there
you go yeah so you went from 10 bucks to
100 bucks french fries to to 100 bucks
right that's that's a big difference
yeah yeah well she's not going to go
there but the point is when you walk
into something with with education you
have to add to that experience would you
hire this person if she's one of the
ones right now like she appli she she
sends her resume and Rob sees it I'm the
girl that you guys talked about on the
podcast would you hire her with the
answer that she
gave I i' give her a zoom I'd give her
absolutely give her a zoom interview
I'll tell you I'll give her a great
interview and I'll really Probe on some
things and I will give her a serious
look mhm you'd give her a serious look
on what she's saying okay all right um
you know I'd also ask her what she's
thinking with the 880,000 student loans
and how did it end up there I want to
look at judgment I want to look at a lot
of things but that goes quick these days
what goes quick these days the uh the
tuitions are out of control and they're
getting Government funding and they're
doing the rock climbing wall an opening
week they're putting on concerts at the
school and then they're doing a sex toy
gay pride week so all this stuff cost
money and then all that money is being
spent and then these people are coming
out with a degree that doesn't help them
in the real world so then they're
getting mad now Trump you was labeled as
a scam when people weren't making the
money they thought they were they sued
Trump you and the left chears about it
but now the left is is complaining
they're not getting any value out of
their education well then sue the
university and say give me a degree that
can work for me if I'm willing to work
and by the way during an interview it
may turn out that this is just an angry
liberal person that's just spouting off
and is not employable so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
a